I love me some good Twitter drama look
at this
this is awesome so after this contrast
set paper appeared and I've done a video
on that the author of it tweeted it out
with there one of thee these long
twitter threat with screenshots and all
this seems to be the new marketing tool
of academics and as you know I'm not a
fan of this paper I think that the
number that comes out of such a contrast
that is very either useless or a
counterproductive and you can see my
video on that in any case out there
there was another researcher exactly
Lipton who felt like he needed to jump
in here saying before the media flips
and retweet party gets out of control
this idea exists has been published and
has the names and a clear justification
is called counterfactually augmented
data this is amazing look at that and
here's the published paper of course and
if we look at the published paper this
is it right here of course Zack Lipton
is an author on that paper and so let's
just just read the abstract I haven't
read the paper but let's just read the
abstract it um so I have it classically
I have it here my nifty thing here so we
can analyze it so this paper if you read
the abstract eat those sounds similar
right
despite alarm over the reliance of
e-learning since blah blah blah blah
spurious correlation so it talks about
the same problems and what do they say
given a document in their initial labels
we task humans with revising each
document so that it accords with a
counterfactual target label retains
internal coherence and avoids
unnecessary changes right so this sounds
very similar to what these contrast sets
do so the counterfactual target label
would be
the necess neccessity of the contrast
set to change the label retains internal
coherence which is the in the contrast
that is simply given by it supposed to
conform to the intent of the theta set
makers which the intent probably
includes internal coherence and it
avoids unnecessary changes that conforms
to the contrast set only searching in
the local environment of a test set
example so you see that the definition
of these is pretty similar then we go on
and say they say class restrained on
original data fail on their
counterfactually revised counterparts
and vice versa this experiment was also
done by the contrast at paper and then
they say classifiers trained on combined
data sets performed remarkably well just
shy of those specialized in either
domain so immediately we see some
differences as well right
the main difference I see is they say we
task humans and then they train on the
they train on the counterfactually
revised counterparts which probably
means they use some mechanical Turk's
here they say humans because if you want
to create a training data set you need
lots of data so they probably take a
data set and run its training data set
again through something like Mechanical
Turk to get annotations this is exactly
what the people of the of the contrast
sets claim is wrong with the current
pipeline and they so in here we have
this this thing counterfactually
Augmented stuff so in the contrast sets
what they say is we actually need the
experts to do this that this the these
humans are exactly the wrong people to
make the data sets so it has the CFA has
some elements correctly the same namely
how they construct these labels but who
construct the labels and for what reason
so here it's experts and for what reason
it's for tests
it they say the experts that make the
data set should provide an additional
contrast test set so this is I mean if
if this is just my opinion if this is
the same idea of course it's very
similar but if this counts as the same
idea the 95 percent of all research
counts as the same idea as something
that jurgen schmidhuber has done in the
1990s which of course here in
schmidhuber will eloquently argue
exactly he invented ganz basically the
same thing so yeah so if this is it's
not the same like I have to say this
it's very close but it's not as I
understand they even cited the other
ones so then that the bickering starting
this is funny I'm like this this is just
funny to me so it's a Clinton jumps here
it says this has been published has a
name and a clear justification
it's called contraction the data here is
the published paper we just looked at
this right and then Matt Gardner answers
and he says Zach and diviners work is
sorry and Devia deviance work is
excellent I recommend you all go look at
it
I wrote provides a different concurrent
take on similar issues right and I think
here are some one comments that so he
says it is in the related work section
although mischaracterized in miss
attributed as contemporary work so
position is really that it is and of us
stole an idea and they were apparently
in contact with each other during that
so this Matt Gardner here says what the
differences are it says we take a
geometrical view we demonstrate suit in
a wider variety I mean for all intents
and purposes if you go through any of
the research go to computer vision go to
NLP you'll find like the say exact I
have like I have
I reviewed two papers each year that
want to produce data that better defines
the decision boundary like these people
here I mean this
there's ideas just get rehashed over and
over in slightly different form these
two are particularly close but and then
see how they bicker our paper was
finished two months after theirs and
then they say we started the project
well before and so on why do we feel
defensive and then he answers again with
[Music]
this is absolutely false
our paper was drafted in July your paper
was finished the night before the ACO
deadline this is not two months ago but
half a year it is nothing to do this
why do you presume do you know when we
started drop the nonsense we did this
work in May 2019 present the public
results in July poster didn't ever drop
the posturing so much of what you're
doing here is the very cancer in the
system I mean I I agree just you know
slightly refining ideas that previously
were there is very bad problem in
academia so this is actually correct to
point out but I don't think that this
particular instance is particularly bad
and then says I'm afraid you're simply
mistaken as a history of publishing
similar so I've something like the last
thing I'm gonna say I just invite you to
read this beautiful the last thing to
say here if if this counterfactually
augmented data if this is in fact the
first instance of this general idea to
produce counterfactually augmented data
that that that does actually fulfill
these criteria I would be extremely
surprised because this is nothing to do
with deep learning right and the real
novelty in her field is mostly deep
learning so I'm pretty sure someone must
have thought of something like this when
everyone was just doing grammars and
manual features and things like this so
I'm I would be extra
really surprised if this hasn't been
there in one form or another and why the
authors of that should make exactly the
same argument that being said it is
fairly close like that the fun part here
is that it is actually a fairly similar
idea except after so the idea itself is
fairly similar but here the focus is on
different things and it's also on
different datasets and I believe yeah as
I said 95 percent of research falls into
exactly this category so much fun check
it out yeah bye bye